the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video in this video
i will let you hear some of the audio
from the show idris elba does with his
wife over on audible in one of their
upcoming episodes they sat down with
house of the dragon's writer and
co-creators ryan condell and george rr
martin now that the release of house of
the dragon's first season is on the
horizon the show's creators will do a
run of interviews to hype up the release
of their new show
unfortunately they haven't released the
full episode yet but they did release a
short sound bite of ryan and george
admitting which one of them actually
cares about the fans the most i'm sure
some of you will find this to be very
interesting especially when you consider
what george rr martin also said in one
of his recent blogs about the winds of
winter this was when he gave a lot of
fans reasons to believe he no longer
cares about them wanting his next book
in the song of ice and fire series now
in case some of you don't remember that
update from his website this was when
george said i look around and i don't
know where last year went i blinked and
it was gone not a year that i will be
mourning much any more than the year
before unfortunately so many of my
friends died as well as celebrities of
all sorts it was a year best forgotten i
did however get a lot of work done last
year an enormous amount of work if i'm
being honest now i'm not complaining i
like working i like writing editing and
making shows there is nothing i like
better than storytelling now i know i
know for many of you out there there is
only one thing that matters i am sorry
for you they all matter to me
yes of course i am still working on the
winds of winter i have stated that a
hundred times in a hundred venues having
to restate it endlessly is just
worrisome i made a lot of strides on the
winds of winter in 2020 in less than
2021 but less is not none
the world of westeros the world of a
song of ice and fire is my number one
focus and will remain so until that
story is told but westeros has become
bigger than the winds of winter or even
a song of ice and fire
now there were a lot of fans who saw
this as him admitting the winds of
winner is actually no longer his number
one focus although he stated the
opposite in fact some fans even said he
sounded bitter or even annoyed with his
fans honestly that is for you to decide
now what's interesting about this new
interview is ryan condell who is one of
the showrunners and co-creators on house
of the dragon says he cares about the
fans more than george the reason why
this is interesting because george does
not correct him which makes me think he
agrees with what ryan said
now this is good news for house of the
dragon fans because i think this
continues to show that ryan honestly
does want to get things right by
delivering a great show however
if you're a george rr martin fan you
might see this as more evidence that he
is growing resentful with at least a
certain section of his fandom now i
myself won't go that far but i can also
certainly understand if you do let me
just show you what he said then you can
decide for yourself this might be
another one of those instances where
some of us will overanalyze something he
did or didn't say you be the judge
who
cares about the fans the most
um
i think i do at this moment do you i
think i asked that yeah it has to be
that has to be me because i feel like i
you know
the
george already has his fans and and the
fans of the book are
numerous and strong it's you know it's
it's our job uh miguel and my job to
create a fitting successor show that
keeps them happy
um that is a lot of pressure actually
yeah i talked earlier about the
relationship
in comic fandom and science fiction
fandom and
i love the fans although i do think
twitter and the internet and social
media has brought out a viciousness that
i never saw in the old days and uh love
and hate are
very close
and um particularly with uh hot passion
uh something like comic books or any
established franchises and
i think you probably actually can speak
to this uh the controversy about james
bond
that uh is going on for you and also
before that the the dark tower i suspect
stephen king fans were vocal about that
and
i i i get you know when's the winter the
six book is late
and i can get a hundred
good comments but there's still going to
be a few fans out there who are going to
remind me of it you know on my blog or
whatever and i say
happy thanksgiving and they say never
mind happy thanksgiving with the book
i just want to say i'm very sorry for
that thanksgiving post george
i just i'm a big fan i just really want
to read the book
[Music]
[Music]
you